[Music]
thank you
in the 1950s school children in the
United States learned all the basics
Reading Writing arithmetic as well as
one other thing what to do in a nuclear
attack
first you duck and then you'll cover and
very tightly you cover the back of your
neck your face
on October 4th 1957 American fears of
nuclear Annihilation seem to come one
step closer
it was in the sky a 23-inch metal sphere
placed in orbit by a Russian rocket you
are hearing the actual signals
transmitted by the Earth circling
satellite shock waves reverberated
through the White House leading
President Eisenhower to make a massive
investment in Science Education
the Firepower of this cold war would be
devised by Innovative minds and to leave
the charge Eisenhower established a new
federal agency the National Aeronautics
and Space Administration now
as a new president John F Kennedy took
the helm the Soviets pressed their
advantage
man had his first great success in space
when the Russians pushed a man Across
the Threshold it was the propaganda coup
of the year
in response President Kennedy threw down
the gauntlet I believe that this nation
should commit itself
to achieving the goal
before this decade is out of Landing a
man on the moon and returning him safely
to the Earth
and on July 20th 1969 the world Stood
Still as a decade of intense effort
culminated with Neil Armstrong
descending from the eagle Lander
[Music]
IA
but with that Triumph some Americans
question the need for further investment
in the space program especially when
down here on Earth the country faced so
many challenges
[Music]
NASA's funding was cut significantly and
the last three Apollo missions were
canceled
with that NASA's Focus for the 1970s and
the 1980s turned to an orbital space
station and a reusable vehicle to get
there and this time NASA didn't go at it
alone
Americans and their Soviet Arch Rivals
put aside their differences to jointly
build and operate the International
Space Station a partnership group that
has grown to include the Europeans
Canadians and Japanese whose own space
programs grew considerably during the
1970s and 80s
by the late 1990s Europe's Ariane rocket
had become well established in the
highly competitive market of satellite
launches and by the early 2000s private
Enterprises such as SpaceX blue origin
and Virgin Galactic brought space
exploration into the realm of big
business
thank you
meanwhile scientific exploration of the
cosmos transitioned into a robustly
international Endeavor with uncrewed
missions probing every planet in the
solar system but to a species of
explorers nothing compares to the dream
of human space exploration and in 2022
NASA in partnership with European
Australian Japanese and Canadian
counterparts launched the Artemis
program to establish a permanent human
presence on the moon and route to
eventual human exploration of Mars
probing farther still a new generation
of internationally funded space
telescopes will seek to unravel the
origin of the universe the nature of
dark matter and dark energy and whether
there is other life in the cosmos
space
final frontier will very likely
revolutionize our understanding of the
cosmos in our place within it
and so with excitement and humility we
enter the new golden age of space
exploration
[Music]
good evening
welcome
thank you it's been a long time since
we've been here live right last time we
were able to join you in person was back
in 2019 a lot has happened since of
course it is science itself that has
allowed the world to start to get back
to normal right it is remarkable how
quickly the vaccine was developed and
then ultimately tested allowing us to
get to a place where life is getting
back to normal there have been
tremendous developments of course in the
time since we have been here because
although the world had to sit still
science science went forward in a moment
we're going to take that summary that we
just showed you and push it forward and
other programs that we will be talking
about here at the festival James Webb
Space Telescope we will talk about the
insights and Innovations from that
particular machine a whole variety of
other developments will also be
available but there's one one that
perhaps I'll just quickly make a
reference to which is you know the
Breakthrough is in artificial
intelligence which are pretty remarkable
I mean how many people have played
around say with with chat GPT
right
and say about half of you have right it
is I mean it's impressive right I mean
it's it's impressive but I have not been
as
really convinced as some that this
system really is in intelligent right in
some ways it is in some ways it's not so
I mean just to sort of Give an example
just a couple hours ago I asked chat GPT
to try to integrate it into the program
to write me an opening joke
for tonight's programs I asked it to to
write me a joke
about space exploration
and because I was thinking I might
actually deliver that joke to you I said
you know do it
write it in the voice of Brian Greene
okay so it came back and I'm going to
give you
um this really rollicking piece of humor
from this intelligent system here's the
joke the joke is
why did the astronaut cross the road
it's a promising start the answer is
to get to the other side of the universe
yeah
now when I read that
you know as a as a humble representative
of the species I felt pretty good right
because you know this is not really what
I would call intelligent intelligent
humor so you know I I wrote back to chat
GPT and I said you know that was that
was kind of a lousy joke I asked you I
asked you to write a good one you know
why did you write such a bad joke and
chat GPT came back and said
well you asked me to write it in the
voice of Brian Greene
a little bit scary right anyway so
tonight's program we are going to travel
across the cosmos to get an update state
of the art look at what we have been
doing in the arena of space exploration
broadly defined
let me introduce Thomas zurukin who from
2016 to 2022 was the associate
administrator for the science Mission
directorate at Nasa that is NASA's head
scientist where he oversaw the
development of many of the initiatives
that we will be discussing here tonight
welcome Thomas
also with us here in Brisbane is odd
beaniels art is the chief technology
officer of the Australian space agency
where she is responsible for defining
the scope of Australia space programs
and managing their technical development
and final delivery welcome on
[Music]
we have two other participants who are
joining us remotely first joining us
from the Hague is Kirsten McDonald of
Esa of the European Space Agency Kirsten
is the utilization planning team lead at
the directorate of human and robotic
exploration leading groups that are
responsible for transporting European
astronauts and payloads from Earth to
the Moon and Mars
[Music]
and finally with us from Paris is misaki
Fujimoto deputy director general of The
Institute of Space and astronomical
Sciences of Japan's Aerospace
Exploration Agency or jaxa his team has
successfully intercepted and recovered
samples from an asteroid and is
currently planning a mission to return
samples from one of the moons of Mars
all right so welcome to everyone to this
conversation thanks so much for joining
us and we're going to be exploring you
know the the world wide effort really of
our species to take the next step into
the final frontier and one of the big
questions that we will be talking about
it's a question I think
just about everybody has an interest in
which is are are we alone right is there
is there life out there in the cosmos
and just to get us going you just want
to ask everyone your sense I mean if we
were able to answer that question
presumably in the positive it'd be hard
to definitively answer it in the
negative
how much of a big deal would that be I
mean what kind of impact do you think
that would have Thomas look Brian I
studied physics because of the class on
the history
and that was a class on the copernican
revolution when we figured out when
science figured out that
the sun was in the center of the solar
system and not the Earth it changed
everything not just our understanding of
science but the whole power structure uh
both on the you know the kingdom side
but also the religious side I think
finding life is a similar type of
Revolution kind of one that takes life
from one life in our experience to many
lives I think it will be enormous uh in
its uh impact and frankly hard to
protect yeah or how about your view on
that I think I would agree with that and
I also think that discovering another
extraterrestrial life and it's not if
it's really it's really when and it's
really are we going to be able to
discover that that's really confident
right yeah that's great okay the odd
says and the probability says that they
will probably be life out there but how
we how are we going to to find it but I
think finding such a such a discovery
having a such Discovery will unite a lot
of people as well I think you've heard
about the Blue Marble effects when
apparently when you go to space and you
see how small the planet is
um you really realize that we are one
and Humanity living on the planet I
think if we discover that you're not the
only one it will change your perspective
on things very much so um they will have
a massive impact Kirsten how about how
about you yeah I think I agree with both
Odin Thomas
I realized that um
given the chances and all the stars in
the galaxy there's such a high
probability that they're there there is
life existing elsewhere and similar to
the blue blue dot Blue Marble feeling
you also may feel like yeah we really
aren't alone out there
um and maybe that that helps us justify
everything we're doing for planetary
protection and and see the universe as a
space that we're sharing with other
organisms
misakis what do you think if we were to
end Cosmic loneliness and know that
there are other intelligent life forms
out there what would the impact be how
big of a discovery would that be yeah
I'm maybe I'm not directly answering
your question but I haven't ambivalent
feeling about this issue
if you look at how many stars we have in
the galaxy life must be there but on the
other hand professionally I'm really
asking the question about what made our
planet habitable at all and this really
seems like a miracle that our planet is
habitable so
yeah I really don't know I have a really
I really have an ambivalent feeling
about this question but anyway it really
makes us ask good questions on and on
and on and that's what I like about this
question
so let's jump into some of the details
so odd if we can begin with you
especially since what you're working on
is right here in Australia of course you
know the square kilometer array is a
device that may give us insight into
this very question about other life out
there in Casa can you tell us something
about what that device is and how it
potentially could detect signals so we
started doing city in Australia before
dsk started and so Parks the telescope
in in New South Wales has been I think
dedicating 800 hours in total to listen
to signal in space so the the idea is to
combine radio telescopes with very
powerful Computing and algorithm to make
something out of this signal and and now
that we are planning to do the SK so I
think in total the SK is going to be 512
station in West Australia
um next year is going to be already
operating I think we're gonna have six
antennas and then the next year 20
additional and then 60 Etc in a couple
of years we will live in Australia a
capability that never exists before so
with that capability of listening to
signal and Whisper Far Far Away
um they're gonna be always some
algorithm running in the background so
the esk will do its first purposes to
look into astronomic discoveries but
always in the background there will be
some algorithm running out so that we
can find some some signal we have a
pattern there are not something produced
by nature and a natural object or
something that would come from a natural
source and so the old ideas and I think
Thomas can talk about this much better
than me but that's what we call techno
signature and biosignature is can we
find some organism by your organism
somewhere and this is they look into the
pattern of the signal is it something
that that's being produced by
an intelligence somewhere
and so you already made reference to it
but Thomas maybe you can take a little
bit further so you know in the old days
when we spoke about seti it was just you
know these radio dishes just you know
looking for some kind of signal but can
we now go beyond that approach to look
for more refined signatures of of Life
out there
I think there's a huge Evolution that
happened in this field uh as you said
like you know from listening to deep
space to really uh frankly bringing the
tools of AI and machine learning to
massive amounts of data and not only
looking at the radio space but also at
the visible in addition to that uh see
what happened uh and and frankly
sometimes we forget how close these
discoveries are to the present roughly
uh six years ago was a paper that came
out that basically said look if we look
at the statistics of planets planets
outside of our galaxy for each star in
the universe there is at least a planet
you know so for me uh what happened now
and what we have spent a lot of time on
is looking at the atmospheres of those
planets and with the James Webb Space
Telescope for example we can look at
them and frankly Not only would we hear
kind of noise like radio noise you know
from you know football games in in
various places I know the football is
different depending on where you go
right but the excitement is the same or
more here frankly in Australia I've been
watching at the TV it's like it's
incredible with what they do anyway so
so uh it must hurt enormously by the way
but but some of them are insane I don't
know how you guys do without equipment
you know helmets and things but that's a
for a different program yeah yeah but
but but but also really looking at the
atmosphere see the atmosphere really
changes because humans are here and
because especially bacterial life is
here it totally changes the atmosphere
so looking for those signatures as well
is really one of the goals of techno
signatures yeah yeah so you know if
we're looking for signatures of what
sort of the The Remnant the detritus the
pollutants that come from technological
advancement they could be doing that for
us too right so our our garbage May well
be the signature that that they are
looking for to find us right and so do
we you know do we need to be concerned
about that do we do we worry about
revealing ourselves is this something
that we're certain is an Enterprise that
will not ultimately be to our detriment
well I would say if the answer to that
question is yes I would say oops
because it's too late right get off
since you know since the 40s we fight
we've started to emit in all directions
and frankly I think there there are two
ways that looking at everything new and
I think it's important to look at when
we take a new technology and kind of a
new approach it's important to kind of
say what what if and to think through
that and really make sure that there's
no damage right but generally speaking I
think it's also important that we can of
do there uh some of these I mean frankly
all these movies you showed earlier
right there people daring things that
were not done before and on the average
you know those things is what brings us
forward yeah so you know
almost everybody made reference to the
fact that from a probabilistic
perspective you know you look at a tiny
patch of Sky you stare at it long enough
say with Hubble or the James Webb you
see an enormous number of galaxies in
the tiny patch each galaxy has you know
hundreds of billions of stars as you
just noted each one of those has a
planet so so the odds seem seem good
from that perspective but for somebody
namely you Thomas who spent so long at
Nasa do you think the tools that we now
have
are likely to find that life if indeed
the probabilistic reasoning is correct
so look at kind of what happens you know
it's almost like climbing a mountain in
the fog you never quite know how close
you are to the top right you know so so
the way uh see what happened at Nasa uh
that was really important and similar
things happen across the world is is in
uh 2018 uh the purpose statement for
NASA was changed to include finding life
elsewhere so the purpose of NASA in part
together with Earth observations and
exploring the universe and uh with
humans you know having an astronaut core
is to find life elsewhere so what I've
done when I was uh uh as an head
of science I'm like I try to do all I
could for example bringing back samples
from Mars uh is what the reason for that
is to find is there a kind of extinct
life on the surface of Mars why wouldn't
there be three billion years ago there
was a lot of water so forth going uh
with Clipper uh in 24 uh to Jupiter
trying to see whether Europa is a
habitable world you know and also uh
kind of exploring other things so so for
me
um I think there's a
there's a very good chance so so the way
I do this I always try to see do I bet
my house it's like really bad if the
back goes wrong yeah I bet my car and
you know I have a decent car but not a
Ferrari or do you bet my life so so so I
bought a car that in 20 years we know
the answer at least for the artery a lot
well that's pretty good yeah I mean
based on a lot of the the things we're
doing is putting your money in your
mouth is it Kirsten so Issa is certainly
involved deeply in trying to find
exoplanets and so can you give a sense
of the projects that I guess are
underway now or in the planning stages
to advance the list of exoplanets that
we have discovered sure sure
um so Issa is focusing on conditions for
Planet formation and looking at the
emergence of of the potential emergence
of life so already in 2019 there was a
launch of uh kiops and kiopsis is there
to look at planets that were already
aware of their existence but try to
measure their mass as it passed in front
of its star
and from that measurement then measure
the size to estimate the mass and
density of the of this planet that's
this the first part already launched in
2019 then they'll it'll follow with a
Plato Mission Plato mission is going to
be looking at earth-like planets that
are going around our sun-sized stars and
this will essentially let us know if
there's there's planets in this
habitable zone where there may be the
existence of liquid water
and then following that we're going to
have the aerial Mission and Ariel is
coming in the next decade and it will
really focus on looking more and more
into the atmosphere of these planets
and right now how many exoplanets have
we found
it's in the thousands it's it's a little
bit over five thousand a little over
5000. so it's over 5000 or so and of
those the fraction of those that you
know are either Earth-like or in a
habitable zone associated with the
particular star what number we're
looking at there
estimating that we'll observe at least a
thousand or so in that in that zone so
at least in the first mission of kiopsa
looking at
planets that are roughly the size of um
uh between Earth and Neptune size and
then in that zone that's more
inhabitable but it's hard to say yet
yeah so it's about 20 or so depending on
how you look of everything we found are
kind of have our candidates in that zone
which with the numbers we're talking
about 20 is basically one right that
changes anything so and frankly kind of
if you go to a meeting with a lot of
professionals they fight about that
number right and some people have
actually argued that it the numbers
should be higher because there's certain
biases because see it's a lot easier to
observe big things you know and a lot of
the big things are not earth like
Jupiter and Saturn are much bigger and
you know Neptune and others are much
bigger so so it's so there's a lot of
chances so given a masaki I just want to
go back and drill a little bit down
further on on the question that I began
with with the following framing
if we do to discover life beyond Earth
well it took life on this planet roughly
a billion years to to take hold and you
know on the order of billions of years
for intelligence to emerge so billions
seems to be the relevant time scale when
we're talking about life and
intelligence so with that it would
suggest strongly that would be an
incredible coincidence if we discovered
extra trust your life which was at
roughly the same level of advancement as
we are either they're going to be well
behind us or perhaps well ahead of us
and we're talking ahead with scales of
billions of years we know what happened
in just like a hundred years on on this
planet with human beings we're so
different technologically from what we
were 100 years ago imagine what we're
going to be like a billion years from
now if we're here of course so so if we
take that into account
does that change our perspective on the
impact of say encountering
extraterrestrial intelligence when we
recognize that we probably won't be able
to communicate with them not because the
languages are different it's just we'll
be so it's vastly different stages of
development
well that reminds me of a joke that if
you're too intelligent
you might start killing yourself and you
don't you don't stay long on the planet
so uh maybe we're in that crisis now but
well that maybe that was a bad joke
but um
that's right wow uh should I stop here
feel free to continue
yeah but you keep on asking about life
but um
for us it's the Prebiotic Evolution that
already seems like a miracle
so we have just completed a mission by
the name Hayabusa 2.
we return samples from a primordial
asteroid
and we found
um 20 000 organic Mercury inside
so it seems like we have a starting
material for life already even on the
primordial asteroid a small body
but how do they evolve into something
that's useful for life and how life
managed to use them to maintain life
I think before I asked before wondering
about intelligence I think that's really
uh a building question for us and uh I
think we are having a nice starting
point to address that question
um yeah I think that's where we are now
and so that's actually a remarkable
result that you just sort of spoke to
with pretty even tone right I mean some
of this was announced just a couple of
hours ago if I'm if I'm not mistaken the
the discovery of eurocell one of the
nucleotides in RNA you now have a
definitive discovery of that complex
life sustaining molecule from the
mission that you described is that
correct people's been uh wondering
whether we find it or not but now the
the the scientists now that we find it
they take it for granted
and they're starting ask a different you
know next level questions
absolutely and I really enjoyed this you
know dynamism among the scientists
yeah no absolutely the the crazy and
shocking results of of one generation
become the things that you just shrug
your shoulders in the next so so on I
just have that on on that perspective of
the the would you be excited or
frightened to encounter life that's a
billion years more advanced than we are
as that's the likely thing that would
happen if intelligence is as commonplace
as life itself
very excited and very excited otherwise
yeah oops as Thomas was saying I think
that would be an excellent Discovery and
we have to say that the Hayabusa 2 was
Landing here in Australia I think that
was a very proud moment here and and I
also heard today that you are going to
give some samples to a university of
Queensland here so you're going to have
some sample to learn to play with and
doing all discovery there
[Applause]
that's quite something that being able
to have your hands on the sample like
that and to uh and do studies and and
Discovery so yeah that's very exciting
so so Thomas and we'll move on I just
want to ask one other variation on this
theme if if we were to find
uh extraterrestrial intelligence that
was say a billion years ahead
and then everything that we work on so
hard everything that we care about we
strive to work out Einstein general
relativity Modern Age String Theory
unified if they've solved it all
and we were like you know let's say the
analogy of of we to them is like ants to
us
I could imagine that that would have a
pretty profound but negative consequence
to life on this planet where it's like
what does it matter they figured it all
out they're so far ahead of us like
what's the point
can you imagine that that could be where
it goes
yeah when you asked uh masaki like what
what happens if they contact us I just
remembered I gave a talk in New York
earlier uh this week and some guy told
me they're following him people from
another society and uh yeah so so uh
I I actually I've thought about the same
Brian I kind of for me that
the fact that we're at the same the
question you know the likelihood that
we're at the same level of evolution
largely is that like load is zero
because we're not going to other stores
I'd like to figure out how to go to
other stores but we have not done that
and and uh and how that would affect
right kind of it it you know like
everyone you know we have had
experiments like that you know and one
part of the world that was in a
different kind of evolutionary
environment went to another part and
basically said I'll tell you what to to
do now and generally speaking those are
bad experiences and they're only a
hundred year differences exactly right
only 100 years so if it's a you know I
mean somebody asked me it's like what's
the first question you asked them and of
course the first question is how did you
do it because I I'm the worry I have
right and together with others
especially this week with the release of
of some of the climate data is like hey
like how do we make sure that we we kind
of kind of kind of take care of our
planet because that's what they managed
to do and became multi-planetary species
I I don't I mean I've I've thought about
this and and I don't know whether I have
a good answer but I worry too just like
you're in the indicating yeah yeah I
mean you know Stephen Hawking was fond
of saying that any time a civilization
was visited by another visited in quotes
it didn't usually turn out too well for
them we see this repeated all across our
planet so one can imagine it replicating
in a more dramatic way across the cosmos
but uh masake I just want to go back now
to the discovery that that you made
reference to so the work that you have
been doing with the Japanese space
program has been trying to land and you
successfully did land a vehicle on an
asteroid so you can just tell us about
the motivation for that what you've done
you've already made reference to the
results but just give us a little back
story on that yeah thank you
um so we've been to a primordial
asteroid by the name ryugu
the reason we were interested in
primordial asteroid is is because Earth
was born dry so somebody from the outer
part of the solar system must bring
water and volatiles including organic
compound to make a planet habitable at
all
so we've been to the prime or the
asteroid who must have brought those you
know those materials to make our plant
habitable and got the samples back to
make sure that the other who made the
condition available for the habitability
so sample return mission is a is a was a
big technology challenge
we have been to a small asteroid about
which we don't really know before we get
there
and uh after getting there you know all
the details and the engineers start to
make the planning to get the samples
from the surface which we managed to do
perfectly
and then returning samples back to Earth
is also a big deal because you really
have to pitch the capsule precisely into
the desert in Australia umera
and we have to collect the samples
swiftly and bring it back to the
curation facility in Japan so that we
don't have the contamination from the
terrestrial environment on the samples
we did all of them
perfectly almost so we're really proud
of the mission
and the results we're getting from are
now analyzing the samples is really
really great and we're really proud to
be offering the science opportunities to
scientists on the globe and so do you do
we now have an answer a definitive
answer to the origin of water on Earth
or is that still an open question
primordial Astro is now for sure like
one of the strong candidates that
brought water to Earth how about
water that was already in Earth and out
gas is that still a contender or a
contributor to earth water
well the strongest rival is the comet uh
and then people can analyze the isotopic
ratio of of uh hydrogen
to to make sure that about the mixture
of primordial asteroid versus Comet
about the you know how much how much has
been contributed by which
about the original water on Earth so
that's the big debate happening now
and so yeah go ahead Thomas so I think I
think if you uh went to a science
meeting on this yeah I would uh the
prevailing thought is today that it's
really a mix of uh stuff that comes from
the inside of the planet and from the
outside and and uh and really uh masaki
said it well right kind of it's Comet
asteroids uh used to be the things in
schools were drives like yeah absolutely
not right you know wherever we go
there's uh we find water on these
asteroids and and you know there's a lot
of surprises also kind of how the
structural Integrity of this uh uh this
uh thing I remember uh uh masaki you
know he picked up uh you know the
Hayabusa 2 picked up a sample we did one
with NASA and what we did is we had the
arm that went down and I remember
sitting there on the chair and the arm
hit the surface and we had a
accelerometer in there to kind of make
sure when we hit something hard we fly
away well the arm went right in for a
half a meter on top the spacecraft
because of another measurement basically
said hey I better back off so kind of
don't think of so they're not they're
not really solid rock no yeah it's more
like a ginormous you know like what's
under my bed if I don't clean enough
like sauce right take it off like it's a
ginormous Dust Bunny and you know like
when we when we hit uh when we hit an
asteroid with a spacecraft called Dart
same happened like enormous amounts of
stuff came off it's not it's not rocks
many of these asteroids are not rocks so
do we need to be scared of being hit or
is that more of a myth I mean getting
hit by a Dust Bunny doesn't seem that
frightening it depends how heavy it is
yes right that's true too so so look I
mean it's just it's just different my
point is that there's a lot of surprises
when we look at these uh bodies and I I
you know what I did my I looked up your
uh resume of course and I think you know
we did uh we did our education within
five years of each other and I I
remember I kind of a lot of the things
that we were taught like for example
it's really hard to make Organics yeah
and the answer is it's raining Organics
from the sky right right from the
beginning and and and for me it's just
like there's just a lot of lessons
learned here and you know in this Golden
Age of Exploration kind of the many of
the things we learned just were wrong so
but all the work all the work that's
usually spoken of like you know Harold
Yuri you know putting you know a bottle
that has all the the the sludge that you
imagined was early Earth and then
hitting it with you know bolts of
lightning just electric currents to try
to yield organic molecules is all of
that now sort of secondary because of
the fact that the universe is pretty
good at manufacturing these organic
molecules and they just came down from
space is is that the paradigm shift
yeah that's a that's a really good
question because
people's been
people's been happy detecting amino acid
or nuclear base in in you know astral
material samples
but is that the right question to ask
because does it have to be that
particular molecule
that reigning on Earth or can it be
something more complicated from which
you start processing on Earth
so I think that that's getting to the
burning question now because uh on virgo
we do in addition to amino acid the
nuclear base we are detecting more
complicated molecules that looks useless
as it is but once they Reign on Earth
and start to get processed they might be
the
nice starting point for the you know
subsequent synthesis so I think that's
really the burning question emerging now
yeah so Kirsten uh Isa is also I guess
even working with the Japanese space
agency to have a a comet Interceptor to
take these ideas even further and tell
us about that work yes so the the plan
that Esa has is uh to fly three
spacecraft to uh to a comet and take
measurements simultaneously so that you
can then get a 3D view of uh of the
Comet maybe a hand over to masaki-san
for uh more details as well yeah so what
we really like about this combat
Interceptor mission is that
it's gonna be in the in the L2 Point uh
waiting for something interesting to
come down to the inner part of the solar
system
like uh like an Interstellar Comet or or
a comet that's coming into the inner
solar system for the first time
and once we get that news once we know
that it's coming then we'll send the
spacecraft to make a rendezvous so this
is going to bring us the very first
image close-up image of an Interstellar
object or maybe a
what is it that the the the the comment
that's making the first encounter within
the part of the solar system
so it's really going to be a very
something that we never seen before so I
really like I really like it that we are
part of this uh Mission and so the L the
L2 point you mentioned it the LaGrange
2.8 but I want to quickly just review
what that is and why we would put a
device at that location what do you want
to do is not leave the Earth but be in a
place where you we don't need a lot of
fuel to get going right so if you go to
L2 which is behind uh you know you
looked at the Earth kind of if the Sun
is this way out to us that way uh at 1.5
million kilometers or a million miles or
so in that direction and so what you
want to do you can park it there and it
takes some field very little Fuel and I
like masaki as on just said like you
wait until something really exciting
happens you put the pedal down and get
going so it's a lot it's a lot easier uh
to make that happen uh from there it's
just from a fuel perspective it just
really the right place and frankly by
keeping it there what you can do is make
the spacecraft kind of thermally so that
you don't have to kind of solve all the
problems that you need for a near-earth
mission so you really solve it for the
for the environment that you want for a
Celestial body so that's the other
advantage and they gather the the point
is
previous investigations of comets have
observed them after they've been
profoundly influenced by the sun because
they have come so close if we're out
there at the L2 Point you're sort of
seeing a pristine Comet before the sun
has done anything to it and that
presumably gives us a deeper and clearer
understanding what's going on but if we
move from from asteroids and comets to
some of the moons of planets in our
solar system
we've been surprised and fortunate to
find a lot of interest and interesting
things happening so for instance in in
Jupiter's moons Ganymede Europa Callisto
I guess we have now evidence of of
oceans there and and there are missions
to explore the possibility of Life on
those bodies further so Kirsten I want
to start us off so what's Issa doing in
that regard
Mission coming up actually launching in
well juice the Jupiter icy moons
Explorer and this is actually the most
powerful remote sensing and geophysical
Suite of sensors that we've ever sent to
the the outer solar system so we're
going to be looking at as you said
Ganymede Europa Callisto and trying to
analyze uh the environment around these
uh these um these moons so the oceans or
icy shells the atmosphere of them their
composition and environment and uh yeah
it's an extremely exciting Mission so
with this launch coming up in April
it'll take about eight years of cruising
and then we'll start to see the data
coming from Jupiter also we'll have a
chance to see more about
Jupiter itself and its atmosphere the
magnetic environment Etc
so it's really exciting and especially
so if you reflect on the fact that here
on planet Earth there are many who think
that life may have originated on the
ocean floor you know hot thermal vents
in in our case so it's completely
sensible to imagine that life on these
particular bodies might be in those
Oceanic environments now NASA's also
going to Jupiter's moons is that is that
correct those are distinct missions are
you guys going to sort of bump into each
other on Ganymede or something how's
that going to work yeah so uh the orbit
that the European Space Agency is taking
is is very different than the orbit that
that NASA is doing our mission leaves in
24. and it's gonna take six years to get
there because what we want to do is like
so initial what you'd like to do
uh get in orbit around Europa and
there's like oh let's design that
mission then you figure out that's a
horrible place to be like frankly it's
the the worst place in the whole solar
system I mean because of radiation yes
because Jupiter is the generator of
radiation and frankly Cooks the
spacecraft I mean kind of within hours
within days that spacecraft is is has
accumulated a lot of uh kind of just
kind of ionizing radiation from that
environment so what what NASA is doing
is kind of do pedal orbit in which we
fly by uh Europa uh 40 times or so and
and kind of scan it that way but then go
you know go heal a little bit kind of
farther away what I'm really excited
about is uh there's one instrument on
the the US Mission uh that uh that I
look forward to it it's it's a very
complex Mass back frankly nobody said
that it's absolutely needed now here's
the reason I was so passionate of
putting it on there and that is that
when we went to uh Saturn there's a a
moon nobody could pronounce until it
started spitting water and Organics
called Enceladus right and and I'm like
like I remember when the guy from across
the hallway came to me it's like oh it's
amazing there's alcohols coming out of
enzoidus it's like
you cleaned your instrument with
alcohols on Earth that's why go can I
check it again of course he was right I
was wrong and and uh but but so the
question is does Europa also burp does
Europa also eject from the oceans kind
of uh uh water with whatever is there if
that's the case that mass spec will will
be the best measurement obviously
everything yes absolutely so I'm really
excited for it to gather these two
missions will really Advance the uh you
know juice and and uh Europa Clipper
will advance our understanding of all
these moons and and remember when we
talked about life we never talked about
moons until like the 90s right so so
what an amazing uh just another chance
to create life and entirely different
fashion so art imagine that you know in
one of these missions let me talk
fancifully poetically I don't really
know what the device looks like but
imagine you know we stick some probe
through whatever surface there is a a
periscope down there into the liquid
environment you know and we're looking
around and some creature swims to the
lens and just gives it a nice lick and
keeps on going right so the imagine we
find life what do we do at that point
are we
of the mindset that we got to get the
heck out of there so we don't
contaminate things do are we the mindset
that here's the opportunity to explore
and we just crack open the surface and
start pulling out whatever we can what
do we do what's the the scientifically
sensible and the ethically sensible
thing to do they're asking a very
important question there but don't be
scared you know you do always think of
do we go away or I think we have to
embrace what we don't know and I think
that's what we will do in in space we
want to explore and discover things but
the the point you're raising is very
important and then at the agency at the
Australian space agency we are not there
yet to do some exciting missions that
we've just heard but we are starting and
we are not five years old yet but we're
starting wondering what is the science
Mission we could be doing and because it
starts like that right lots of
scientists look into what is the next
thing we have to discover and then once
once you have that mission you put
Engineers with the scientists and the
engineers build the spacecraft to find
the answer and have these signs and
that's where Innovation happens and
that's that's magical
um we are just doing uh we're studying
about doing a Rover to the moon and
we're asking this kind of questions and
there is a lot of rules and guidelines
and there is the moon treaty there is
there is the Artemis Circle there is a
lot of agreements to do this exploration
in a right way and and we call that
space sustainability we want to make
sure that we don't pollute where we go
yeah now not Everybody Plays the game it
would be good that everybody plays the
game but yeah we have to make sure that
every time you launch something that
goes on the on the pro Bond a probe that
goes on the planet or you you make sure
that it's no microbes Zone nothing it's
it's Ultra ultra clean and that's one of
the reason why all this assembly of
spacecraft are happening in them and
this very clean clean environment so you
have to be very very careful and when we
look into our mission going to the Moon
where we're wondering we're asking all
this question where are the places to
land and and when your equipment dies
where where is it going to die are we
going to decide that on the moon there
is a cemetery where all the Rovers in
end of life go there
um and then that means there is some
material that we can reuse when when
time comes there is no rules yet written
for what we're going to do on the moon
there is there is guidelines but there
is no no real rules I mean that that's
kind of scary in a way I mean right here
we have
Representatives leaders or past leaders
of four space agencies that are fairly
friendly countries right and there are
other space agencies where it's perhaps
a little less friendly and there's no
you know I remember like as a kid in
Star Trek there was the prime directive
right not to interfere broadly defined
and they they broke it every episode
right um and so so can we get to a place
where there is a worldwide agreement on
on the right way to behave in these
circumstances is that naive to hope that
we could get there
but I I don't think it's naive I mean we
have the Corpus the community of out of
space
um policies so people are meeting
together all the countries are meeting
together
um and all the countries you know China
as well Russia as well
um and they're agreeing on guidelines
they're ratifying rules some are just
guidelines but that that exists there
are forums they are meeting twice a year
and to to drive all these rules and I
think we have good guidelines for all
the activities around the earth
um there's 21 long-term sustainability
guidelines like when you launch a
spacecraft after X number of years it
needs to burn back in the atmosphere and
free the space so I think there is a lot
of things happening around and how do
you enforce that do you have a space
police not yet
um so there is still a lot of questions
on how do you enforce all this but for
the Sicily now so all the space between
um Earth and the moon and on the moon
and around the Moon there is nothing and
I think we have to be I'm speaking with
the Artemis so call there is 22 people
who have 22 countries who have signed
this 30 Miss account so how are we going
to go back to the Moon together we're
sharing best practice and we're trying
to be
proactive on this and how are we going
to do this together
um but it's it's not straightforward
yeah Thomas did you want to add to that
no look I mean before uh we don't
interfere with each other which is
absolutely essential right we want to be
sure that agencies from all over the
world can can go explore that's what we
want to and can do before we do that we
need to be absolutely transparent what
we want to do I'm going to go to that
body I'm going to fly there that's what
I'm going to do I'm going to try to land
there that's the transparency comes
first so for for us that's really what
the Artemis of course are about it's
like we're committing that we're telling
you up front what are we going to do and
what we're going to try what are the
payloads that are there and frankly
there's some rules we're going to use
for example in the areas of the Moon
where there's a lot of potential Water
Resources we're not going to put a lot
of pollutants in right so we we want to
make sure that kind of and actually we
quantify what the fuel is that we're
bringing so so somebody can know at the
end that's what went in there and and so
for us transparency comes first to me we
need to figure it out see the issue is
it's a new problem
like we haven't been to the Moon kind of
uh you know with humans for a long long
time and uh you know besides uh the uh
the Chinese Lander uh on the far side
and you know uh there haven't been many
other Landers for a long long time and
and frankly the Chinese told us where
they're going to land ahead of the
landing that which is they're very
transparency that we want and so but
we're gonna have a dozen a dozen
missions in the next two or three years
uh to the Moon you know every one of the
agencies that is represented here has at
least one Mission uh you know the US is
launching three times next year yeah uh
this year this year alone three times to
the moon and so so so it's an important
thing and we need to solve it so let's
let's turn then to to exploration of the
Moon and um on perhaps just give us a
sense there are some who I would imagine
when thinking about humans going to the
Moon would say why would we do that we
got there there's not a whole lot that
you know is there that is to explore why
would we put the resources in to go back
to the Moon what's your perspective on
that
we studied on the lands we went on the
on the ocean then he went in the air and
then lower Soviet moon is next and then
smells and then we continue that's in
our human nature to explore and go
further but do you see it as a stepping
stone absolutely absolutely and I think
whatever we learn to live in a sustable
manner on the moon
there is always learning back for making
our life on Earth better we always I I
like to say that we do space to improve
our life on Earth and even when we do
space exploration and when we send human
on the moon and Beyond it's to
understand Earth better to understand
the formation of the earth to understand
where we are going where we are coming
from
um everything I mean especially every
year they are publishing a volume of all
the patent and invest invention that we
are using on Earth because of all this
exploration we've done so by going on
the moon we're going to improve a life
on Earth that's that's for sure and
that's going to be a test bed to go
further but before we go to the Moon
before sending people on the moon we
need to start preparing everything and I
think that's where Australia has a very
big role to play because of our mining
industry and remote and resourcing
Industry we know how to do remote
operation very far I mean I always talk
about that story the first time I went
to see a resourcing emission control in
Perth I entered in the room and I
thought am I in Houston that took the
wrong wrong door I was very there was a
gravitas in this room there was a lot of
people working concentrating and
different pods organized and I
approached a pods there was one lady
here and she was drilling she was
Drilling she was actually controlling 10
drilling operations that were opening 2
000 kilometers away in the pilbara
region so far away harsh environments
hot cold a big like space two thousand
kilometers away the space station is is
400 500 kilometers away and she was
doing all that using communication vrgo
satellites so 36 000 kilometers and high
so a bit of delay and one person doing
10 operation when usually when you have
you know a Rover on Mars you have one
Rover and 200 people dealing with this
so that was interesting so we have
expertise and experience in doing this
and so this is what our Trailblazer
Rover program is about we want to show
to the world that we are the best in
doing remote operation on the moon we
can prepare the moon we can find analyze
regoliths extract resource that we need
from and we can bring that expertise to
them and whatever we're gonna learn
there we're gonna do things better on
Earth as well and so you're leveraging
an expertise that Australia has to
contribute something iconic to this
Mission misaki Japan is taking a similar
tack right you you also are leveraging
something that you have gotten
particularly good at which I guess is
precision Landing can you tell us about
that yes we have a a small technology
demonstration mission to show that we
can do the Pinpoint Landing
and that Lambda also has a way of uh we
call two-stage Landing you know you
by that way
you can land on a rough terrain so we
will have the technology to do the
Pinpoint Landing and the way to land on
the rough train at the same time then we
will develop our program
um
and that program is driven by science
objectives but the the design is that
um if you want to ex if you want to
develop your skill if you want to deal
with your technology so that you can
explore relatively freely on the surface
of the Moon maybe science is a nice
precursor
so that was the thinking behind our
program so we will try to deploy a
network of seismometer
and a network of
um radio telescope on the surface of the
the moon so that's our future program
and so Thomas
you already made mention but I'd like to
go into it a bit now that the Artemis
program has recently been initiated and
the goal there I guess part of the goal
is to have the first permanent base
station on the moon as odd said use that
perhaps as a stepping stone to Mars
where are we in that program and what
are the key things that we need to get
done to to push this program forward
yeah so uh 2022 was a really important
year because Artemis one lifted off the
launch pad and of course that was
together with European Space Agency with
the European service module and uh at
the Orion just an absolutely incredible
uh you know start to that we are now
working with our partners uh uh with
NASA and all the partners that were
working on really two missions the first
one is to get the first kind of humans
back to the moon and in this case like
the Apollo 8 go around uh the moon and
swing around and come back and then the
the next one of course is to have kind
of an outpost because remember what you
want to do is go to the Moon then and
have this station but also uh learn how
to go to Mars and so so it's the
Skateway that we're uh working together
on that all of this comes to uh it will
be launched in 25 you know and so and
it's had more or less on track on
schedule so uh probably the one thing
that that I'm so it's roughly on track
uh needless to say that these things are
never easy right you know if I've done
it a lot of missions where I went in
front of Congress that we're exactly on
track then I come back to the office and
said oops we found some problem it's
like okay what do I do now so uh look I
mean the team is really great and very
motivated uh we want humans back on the
surface uh of uh the moon because what
you said is we want to have a research
station like we have in the you know in
Antarctica for example in which we
really can have humans there and also
robots that uh frankly do research
together with humans and we can uh go
after the questions that we have in our
minds so you mentioned robots and that
was a question I wanted to go to some
would say that it'd be so much less
expensive to not have to worry about
life support systems if we just sent
robots so Kirsten what what do you think
is the strongest argument
for why it's important that there's
actually a living human being that say
goes on this mission to the moon or Mars
or Beyond I think the the
to perform complex tasks
um the the the capability to
um you know have decision making be able
to find Creative Solutions if anything
goes on when you send a robotic Mission
um you're just dependent on the tools
you came with you can't uh you know have
any creativity of making a solution on
the spot and and coming to that and then
of course um yeah I think uh you know
famous NASA scientist also said that you
know a human can do in a day what the
robot can do in a matter of months
sometimes so I still believe that as we
progress towards the challenges first
robotically of course initially but to
to to really learn how to live and work
on another planet you're solving so many
different technical challenges and these
this this living environment is really
like a microcosm of our own Earth so as
you try to to use the resources you have
in space and you look at all the
different challenges for from from food
from oxygen from water how to solve
these with a sustainable way there's
huge benefits that we can bring back to
earth when you look at climate change
and living more sustainably but we've
already seen for instance that if it
came to an issue of you know creative
smart humor you know chat GPT already
takes care of that right so a little
more seriously what if we imagine there
are sufficient leaps forward in
artificial intelligence couldn't we have
sufficiently
directed and smart robots that really
could do what humans do at least in The
Limited tasks that they will be
presented with in space exploration I
mean Thomas yeah I I think robots are
going to get better and better and
better I I think what what we're trying
to do now and we have uh kennels Rovers
in which we let even uh perseverance on
Mars right now it dries like 10 times
farther than curiosity because we train
it to make decisions and so forth and
we're going to push that pedal down more
but the bottom line is I always ask the
question how how do we do research on
Earth
so you know there's really dangerous
places on Earth like volcanoes right
what what do the best places that do
research on volcanoes how do they do
research and the answer is that puts
humans there together with robots so so
humans go to the volcano together with
uh with robots and and for me that that
humans are such an important contextual
kind of decision maker now in 100 years
or in even in 30 years where will we be
with with the robots I really don't know
we should Advance both and adjust that
balance as we go forward but I I have a
really hard time kind of coming up with
a prediction in which humans are not in
the loop somehow or or are there somehow
also don't forget we relate to humans
very differently than we relate to
robots as well uh that's true but I'm
not sure the relevance of that last
point
for us one of the reasons we do
expiration is to inspire ah not not just
because of the signs result that that
gets written down it's to inspire others
to to kind of do careers that are really
hard like you know be explorers be
innovators and so forth and so for me uh
humans out there they're really
inspiring in a way that a machine often
cannot do so given all that misaki and
given
the dangers of putting a living being in
a spacecraft that's fired off towards
say the moon or Beyond
does Japan have as one of its goals
Landing a citizen on the Moon yes uh
that's often spoken as the
you know near-term goal you know sending
a Japanese on the surface of the Moon
that's
that's part of a reason we have
recruited new candidates recently
but you know hearing all these arguments
let me try to be provocative here
maybe I'm saying something wrong but
still
um when I I'm not from the human
exploration uh division but when I look
at them
they treat astronauts to
to uh too well you know maybe they are
spoiling the astronauts
and what I mean is that why why do we
have to have humans there because we
want her or him to be bold
so uh if we tell we see if we treat the
astronaut as somebody from like I said
celebrities and tell her or him not to
do something
uh then what is it like not not well of
course they shouldn't do something
dangerous but you know
but you know you know what I mean um
so you
astronaut has has to perform its role
and roll will be more challenging in the
future because
it has to be something not something
that robots cannot do
each of your countries have is there an
explicit sense of what level of human
catastrophe the Space Program would be
willing and able to sustain and continue
to move forward I mean we are
catastrophes are an ever-present
possibility yeah right I mean that of uh
frankly uh I don't know kind of running
at Nasa and kind of even launching some
you know the chainsaw Space Telescope if
they're 10 billion dollars sitting on
top of a rocket you start to get into
stoic philosophy right get off because
the things like how do you deal with
that pressure and the answer is you know
like you're not in charge of making no
catastrophe you're you're well you're in
charge of is reducing the risk to
whatever is possible so there will
surely be
catastrophes in the future it's just
that's what history tells us that's
what's going to happen and that's why
it's so important that the why behind it
behind our programs are that that is a
compelling answer we have a compelling
answer for that surely we will survive
these catastrophes if the Y is correct
but I think that will how we do the
research how we uh interact how robots
and humans interface with each other
that will shift over time just how it
has shifted in the past I cannot imagine
going uh to the Moon with an astronaut
without having robots there and frankly
I don't want a vehicle where the the
astronaut can drive and when the
astronaut leaves the vehicle is dead I
want the vehicle to keep driving for the
next years it makes absolutely no sense
to discard a perfectly good vehicle
right but that's what we did in Apollo
right right so so for us it kind of I
think yes there will be challenges
surely will be but you know let's let's
make sure we talk about the why a lot so
one of the other big shifts that's
happened in in recent times of course is
it used to be the case that it was just
governments it was just Nations that had
their space program but now we see that
private business is doing this as well
so what is the impact of say a SpaceX or
or blue origin whatever the leaders
might be on the kinds of things that
we're talking about here and in
particular odd do you have a sense of
the the risk analysis
when it comes to governments I presume
one of the largest is you know the
benefit of what we're doing versus the
lives that it might take but from a
business perspective it's the profit
that you might get versus the loss that
you might sustain it's a different
calculus and what does that do to the
future of space exploration
I I see this differently for me space
either there is business model
so if I do a communication satellite I
can sell the service I can make money so
let the industry run that
however if there is a new technology
that needs to be developed and become
operational I think that small the
government agencies that needs to
develop that technology like Optical
communication just now is is the next
thing once it's proven that it works
leave that to the industry to learn and
you know we saw the picture of the
landing of the Moon in
black and white and fizzy picture when
we're gonna go back we will want to have
like high definition surround sound so
you're gonna have you know Optical
communication is going to be important
um also observation you know whether uh
what what weather is going to be
tomorrow
um space weather what kind of impact is
going to have I think this is a
government rule to provide these
services so that's more a government
Mission I always see this is is there is
there a business model or is there no
business model and I think as soon as
the industry can run that and make
profit let's leave that to them and then
and then the next risk I mean going to
the Moon is risk as soon as they're
going to be a lunar economy things are
going to change again but to your other
questions you know SpaceX has Disturbed
a lot of things and that disruption is
good I think everybody woke up and say
oh what what do we do but I think over
government space agency will always
exist to work together to design the
next mission and and then once your
objectives are defined you let the
industry delivering that but you need to
have the expertise in your agency so you
can Define this Mission you can know if
it's going to be a one billion Mission
or a 50 million Mission so you need to
have
um this expertise still in the in the
agency but let the industry run it and
if they want to do bigger objectives
than the one you said fine let them run
with it but there is a rule with both
um and I don't think it's it's it has
changed so much I started my career at
ISA as always old space I'm now in the
space agency Australian new space and
and I think I think the Best of Both
Worlds before age agencies where we're
Prime so we were building a project I
think today we have been we are
customers we're by your service uh like
send me a Rover to the moon and move
regolit from A to B and once you're done
I pay you my check so it's it's a
governance that has changed but there is
still work for the agencies and they
still works for the industry so that's
just a sort of happy symbiosis between
government and business which in the
best of circumstances can happen but
what role should The Originators you
know the governments play in
constraining or restricting or
regulating what the private companies do
I mean Elon Musk is as we've all heard
has spoken about having a a base on on
Mars like so what role should the
government play in restricting that I
mean for example should we allow there
to be Twitter on Mars
oh
by the way I was really uh wishing I
could live tweet what was masaki-sane is
saying here we get a lot of followers
yes about the astronauts but
um
look in a few minutes you can do that
yeah no look I mean I
so first first and foremost right kind
of it's every government's uh uh
responsibility or every desire that we
don't keep doing the same thing that
there's kind of commercial players that
start picking up that jobs are being
created and and uh frankly the benefit
to the government uh in the case of
SpaceX let's just take that one uh
there's other companies as well and some
of them from the region you know Peter
Beck with rocket lab is incredible
innovator right kind of far we're in New
Zealand and and you know so so uh what
happened
um in the last 10 years or so the cost
of launch has gone down largely uh 30
percent so kind of as a science uh you
know person who likes science missions
yeah what happens every once in a while
you know like I'm like that's really
great because I I actually can do more
science missions now but where did that
come from is it the efficiency of the
capitalist profit motive that found ways
to squeeze down the cost apps absolutely
I mean if if you go to Florida at 2 A.M
any time and you basically go open the
door for SpaceX there's a number of
people working there and there's Rockets
right there like five six Rockets being
worked on because one of them is the one
for two days from now uh the next one is
the one from uh you know five days from
now and you know so the point is it it's
it turned into a factory it's not like
these Exquisite once a month or once a
year uh type of Rocket so it's a very
different uh way of doing it and and for
us that has helped but there's there's
worlds between the Exquisite stuff and
that right kind of frankly I I would
really like multiple competitors right
kind of in every segment I want more
than one company because I want to make
sure that we don't overpay right so we
want to regulate of course we want to
regulate and then I think that's really
important that we make sure that common
resources whether it's certain orbits or
whether it's how we deal with uh you
know poisons or get off like how we deal
with other destinations I think we want
to really think about that that's what
governments do kind of with together
with other governments really figure out
that we don't you know kind of take off
the table future exploration uh for
example I know Esau is really worried
about that the same way we are right so
just a couple more questions before our
time is out here
in terms of a permanent base on Mars
how far away from that are we and is it
something that we should do should that
be a near-term goal of the activities
mazaki thoughts on that you have a
sample return Mission from Phobos so
which means that we will get to the four
Boston coming back
but our interest there is the sample
return Mission yes that's the moon
that's that's almost like an
International Space Station of Mars in a
sense because it's uh it's an orbit
circling around the planet in at a very
low low altitude
so our motivation is to understand the
followers better
because that may instead of having a
having a base on Mars itself maybe we
may have a base on Phobos like a space
station
and perform our exploration of Mars so
so that there's an idea there so that's
the our you know kind of hidden agenda
behind immx mission
and Kirsten what's esa's disposition on
a Mars base a little similar to what
Thomas said earlier a step-by-step
looking at robotic exploration but with
a view of potential human exploration of
the planet
um right now we have the launch of
Rosalind Franklin That was supposed to
be in September last year has now
shifted to 2028 and this Rover is
actually going to visit a location in
Mars that's 300 million years older than
any other location we visited already
it's going to penetrate down with a
drill to a depth of two meters and at
that depth we think that there's a good
chance of finding
um
sample that has evidence of organic life
in some way because it's been shielded
from radiation in the environment with
with these one and a half to two meters
of soil above it and so you know this
could be revolutionary and and tied
together with this rosin Franklin
mission of course we have the the whole
Mars sample return mission in addition
that we're doing together with NASA so
just the complexity of uh already
perseverance Rover picking up the
samples later having a sample retrieval
Lander with um from NASA with a European
sample transfer arm picking up the
samples I mean the first ever launch off
of Mars to send a capsule into space be
captured by the Earth return Orbiter and
then eventually uh have this capsule
re-enter the Earth's atmosphere for for
uh being able to retrieve these samples
so that's a hugely complex Mission and
being able to prove that we can do that
is taking us one step further to say yes
indeeda we could look at a human Mission
to Mars eventually now of course in
parallel we're studying a lot of the
effects of microgravity ISO Nation
radiation on the human body to to also
answer the question could humans even
survive this trip so it's worth already
working our way towards that in parallel
and and then working on this robotic
Mission and and such a yeah such a such
a revolutionary way of
um
uh doing science and and getting samples
back Etc so the choreography is just not
like nothing we've ever done before sure
but I'm assuming that NASA's disposition
and presumably all the space agencies is
that this is a round trip
Journey it's not a one-way mission for
the individuals who go on this given
that would we have to bring all the
return Fuel and and all the resource or
do you imagine that there'll be some way
that we could mine in a manner that
would allow us to get the fuel from the
target as opposed to bring it ourselves
so yes we want to go uh to Mars
absolutely with humans and at the first
trip we're going to bring the fuel
because it's too hard to solve all of
these uh we send it separately like a
FedEx package there on arrival you go
land you go land uh the food you go land
to fuel and you know it's there you do
that first exactly right you know
Precision land then you go land the lap
the science lab yeah you know so so
basically uh one morning uh the humans
land and then they go open the door and
it's like let's get to work right here's
the food here's the lap and so so so you
do that and uh and and then you come
back after so and so much time so so my
guest says I will start working on that
insincerity uh perhaps even developing
it in the late 30s right so for for me
that's that's where I I believe uh where
the where the aspiration should be yeah
and and I I think people expect that I
expect that we go past the moon I I mean
for me the there's excitement about the
moon itself Celestial body but God Mars
is way more exciting together with
Phobos I agree with amazaki kind of we
need to keep our minds open as to how
we're going to use this environment
because it may very well be that the
right way to do it is actually make
Phobos the the base and then go down for
so and so much time and come back up
right so that may be a lot cheaper in
terms of fuel or or overall and and you
know just since we're almost out of time
and we can speculate here so let's say
this succeeds 30s 40s maybe something of
that sort
is there a next step or are we bumping
up against the edge of what manned or
human space travel can accomplish or are
you imagining that we'll go to a moon of
of of of Saturn or Jupiter or something
absolutely absolutely right I'd like to
go to Titan I'd like to put that
somebody said let's go to Europa with
humans I'm like let's not do that like
with all the reasons we already
discussed but tightness and you know
it's like it's an amazing landscape and
you know has an atmosphere it's a lot
easier to land on Titan I'm sure some
other people would come up with other
candidates look exploration doesn't stop
yeah where we are though is we're making
enormous progress right now on both the
robotic and uh human exploration side
and I just really I hope I can you know
a couple decades later there's people on
this stage and they are just absolutely
excited with the destinations that
they're looking for well I can tell you
from a personal perspective there's not
a chance in health that I would go on
any any of those missions would any of
you go
would you go to Mars uh not the first
time yeah
anybody else willing to go to second or
third yeah yeah go we have one taker
absolutely fantastic so in the last
couple minutes you just want to end with
one final question which is really
riffing on the point that you just made
if we were back on this stage or there
are other individuals having a analogous
conversation say a hundred years from
now where would you hope we would be in
terms of our exploration of space misaki
why don't you take it first and we'll go
right down the line
in 100 years
um
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I hope
we learn behave better we learn to
behave better
without with our planet
so
Yeah the more we we explore
I think we're we're really having a
we're really understanding that we
better
better understand our planet much better
than we do now so
yeah you know returning to Earth
and uh securing our planet that I I hope
that's the path we will have in the next
hundred years
yeah I think everybody can agree with
that that's a vital goal that we that we
all share but Kirsten given that
assuming that
masaki's dream that we somehow overcome
all the issues that faces right now
where do you think we'll be in terms of
say exploring the solar system yeah I
think one
will be um you know uh what would be
what would be the Next Step Beyond the
solar system and um
I I really like the idea of of being
able to explore Mars more uh
understanding uh how to use the ice
below the surface and and make it more
sustainable
um also what this the the whole
choreography would be between
Moon exploration Mars exploration and
then next step so potentially another
Moon that's in our own solar system and
uh also having a much better
understanding of our universe as a whole
so if I take um the the Lisa science
program that we have coming up you know
answering some questions about you know
gravitational waves as to understanding
how you know black holes are colliding
and seeing better understanding also of
um you know dark matter and questioning
uh key questions and fundamental physics
that would be answered if we can
understand what dark matter is made of
and is it really an answer or two the
acceleration of our universe so these
are some questions that are going to be
um we'll have more and more data in the
coming decades and then where it will
take us by by 100 years from now it's
very very hard to say but I think the
key point is to keep learning and
exploring
and then um to then take that and see it
looking back on ourselves you know will
we have robotic missions that are
cleaning up low earth orbit and all the
debris that's there are we going to be
able to improve uh the situation of our
own climate based on what we had learned
on living off our planet
well I certainly share your enthusiasm
for the possibility of answering the key
fundamental questions in physics that
would be enormously exciting odd how
about you where do you think we'll be
you know in in roughly a time frame
echoing everything that was said but you
say hopes I'm very optimistic and I
think the progress we've done in the
last 30 years so in 100 years is going
to be even faster I hope in 100 years we
will still have questions to answer
because the day where we don't have any
questions
it's very boring so um we need we need
to continue and Mars is just the
beginning we need to continue
um the the big hope for me is uh
I studied space because space bring
people together I mean look at the
different nationality on on that stage
and when you think of them
during the Cold War the only handshake
between American and the Russian were in
space space those things that I've never
seen anywhere and I was lucky enough to
witness the first launch of Ariane in 79
so the technology the the that what blew
my mind but seeing 12 different nations
there was no race no politics no
religion everybody was partying because
they they shared the same passion the
same goal and this honestly I've never
seen anything else than space making
that happen and that's the big
difference going back to the moon now is
is not a race between two countries it's
everybody together so that's
International so that's a big change and
there is the commercial aspect as well
so I think the next hundred years are
gonna accelerate things a lot and my big
hope is that we're gonna continue asking
the next question like we said we found
we found interesting things
what's the next question we can keep
keep asking questions and continue
exploring and discovering well it's a
beautiful Vision Thomas take us out
well look um
in a hundred years I want to be a United
Earth kind of with a hail planet we can
do it we want to come together and do it
we want to work and and look at the
university the universe is more
beautiful than uh in a hundred years
than it is uh today even remember what
we learned about the university in the
last two decades looking at the night
stars for me is a much deeper experience
today because of what we learned about
it it will be the same and I I would
surely hope will be a multi-planetary
species we've uh basically have managed
to inhabit other places we're there
perhaps we're going there for vacations
perhaps some of us lived there in a
hundred years that should be absolutely
Within Reach and and I surely hope that
we have uh basically uh put an
expedition on the way to go visit
planets of other stars because uh yeah
that's on a time scale of 100 years that
is absolutely Within Reach while we do
that we Inspire here and we make we make
really that positive energy that we feel
when we do uh kind of exploration we
make that something that's really part
of the DNA of our youth even in 100
years fantastic so again do put it on
your calendar for 2123 again it'll be
sometime in late March and we'll have
this uh we'll have this conversation
again please join me in thanking the
panel here
thank you thank you thank you both
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you